row from nerdy nummies she's got a
question oh hi I'm Rosita pansino and
Neil first question when are you gonna
come back with me again second question
what is your favorite Star constellation
and why so she what she hinted it I was
on her show
ah I hope to bake a cake nice it was fun
yeah yeah and how was the cake
you never hate it because there's more
fun making you're right it's the journey
the nerdy nummies nerdy nummies it was
very fun to be on her show and she won't
know when I'm coming back right when are
you coming back you don't call you don't
text you know I'm here mmm I'm here but
anyway what is your favorite constantly
it's my favorite constellation and why
is or Ryan whoa Ryan Ryan the hunter
uh-huh first he sort of looks like what
he's supposed to be kind of yeah you see
he's got a belt is that shoulders his
kneecaps right there's a shield he's got
a shield he's defending himself against
tourists to bull whereas right up above
above him off to the side and so he kind
of looks like what he's supposed to be
unlike the other 87 constellations maybe
about five of them resemble what they're
supposed to be Leo yeah is one of them
Scorpius is another again that was like
that yeah it looks like a scorpion it's
got a stinger but you look at things
like Gemini yeah I see yeah first of all
you're stretching it those are some ugly
twins if that's Gemini so most don't
look like you need now seriously
enhanced imagination to get that so the
88 constellations Orion it smokes the
rest in terms of its what it looks like
what it's supposed to be in addition the
celestial equator so take earth's
equator and project it out onto the sky
correct so what that means is do that
again so what that means yeah sound
effects fine okay so that means is all
the part of the sky above that sit above
the northern hemisphere of the earth and
sky below that sits above the southern
hemisphere that's it Orion okay I gotta
keep it flanks so everybody gets a piece
of a Ryan Oh exactly
it's the ecumenical equatorial the
constellations in the equatorial
constellation that's very cool yeah yes
oh no that's that that's that's very
cool yeah so a little known fact here
when we renovated the Hayden Planetarium
mm-hmm I just floated the idea don't you
know don't judge me I floated the idea
that we might update all the
constellations the things that mattered
to us today
Oh so if it's gonna be a Ryan the hunter
is gonna be a Ryan like the butcher
Orion is like Oh like a warrior right so
we get one of a Ryan the Predator drone
Orion the predator drone or just just
the predator right right no just some
hunter to modern-day hunter is that and
other constellations like Pegasus you
know that's the upside down flying half
a white horse in the sky right in case
you never in case you missed that yes
exactly
actually has a box of stars that looks
very much like a baseball diamond so
there would be just the baseball yeah
baseball constellation I had this idea
it lasted about three minutes from the
committee and then we went on to other
things I like the idea of renaming the
constellations though yeah just to give
it update yeah centaurs anymore yeah and
also it would be a great way to get kids
like interested in moving up I said no
centaurs anymore like they're ever one
you know however in my mind they're
worse than today we have other stuff
that doesn't exist that exist right like
Minotaur like we have like what we have
we have characters from The Walking Dead
you know we have zombies zombies right
they exist but don't exist exactly okay
right Xena
she's sort of Xena the warrior princess
put her up there put put Captain Marvel
up there but Superman up there there's
other culture that we care about today
that's all I'm saying cool
you know what we could do but there are
enough shapes of stars up there maybe
there could be a nerdy nummies cookie
logo as you know that would be the best
advertisement ever I'm just sayin nerdy
nerdy nummies of the cosmos well
anywhere oh I can't wait to get back on
your show thanks for that question so ro
you got more questions bring it on
what is the closest planet to me that is
most similar to earth and when can I go
there okay so here's the thing the
closest planet to earth that is the
planet that gets the closest because
everybody's doing their their thing
right sometimes over there and you over
here at exactly so you want to check it
out when everybody's on the same side of
the Sun the planet that comes closest to
us is Venus Wow and goddess of love and
beauty
oh yeah that's so romantic it is it's
abot the goddess of love and blue beauty
for the planet that important planet is
900 degrees that's what I was going to
say well actually that is kind of love
and beauty in a nutshell you be vapor I
love all love ends that way vaporization
there you go yeah so it's it's a runaway
greenhouse effect with a very dense
carbon dioxide atmosphere note to
earthlings Venus has a runaway
greenhouse effect there's a 900 degrees
so that's the closest but it's not the
most like earth what you really want is
the next closest okay which is so if
Venus is on one side of us on the inside
of us between us and the Sun just on the
outside of us is my eyes right Mar
little farther but we can get there we
have been there right we said we got
probes Road Rovers there now right okay
so Mars rotates once in about 24 hours
now it's tipped on its axis nice which
means in that season there you go it has
polar icecap look at that we at we still
do for now right have polar icecaps call
your travel agent let's go hostile to
life right alright there's ultraviolet
radiation from the Sun that's not
shielded by the ozone in an atmosphere
it sterilizes ultraviolet and life don't
play well together in the sandbox the
high-energy ultraviolet photons break
apart molecules that are organic so you
they don't mix so you want to if there's
life it's under the surface or if they
ever once life it would have needed this
kind of protection life as we know it so
yeah it would be Mars how soon can she
get there she could sign up to be the
first astronaut class to make its first
astronaut making cookies on Mars you
cookies fast crew these are fast anyway
in the oven you ever make cookies yeah
of course is one of the fastest things
you can make yeah get what you know why
because even at high temperature they're
thinner that's right so that the heat
doesn't have to wait a long time to get
to the middle right atom-by-atom
communicating you would end up burning
the outside and the inside wouldn't get
cooked so it's just by the way how all
my cookies come out so thin flat things
can cook in very high temperature
gradients right so if she wanted to cook
a cake on Venus you burn the outer
surface and the inside wouldn't wouldn't
even get touched but if you want to bake
cookies on Venus seconds on the
windowsill right and it's done done it's
like a pizza done put it out by the
toilet in maybe they'll go there you go
nice so but not Mars Mars is several
hundred degrees below zero Oh see you
know what I'm learning from this
conversation what earth is really cool
it is a good used to say sadder is my
favorite planet but it's really earth
yeah that was my second-favorite
yeah so anyway thanks for that question
row are we ever gonna have a space
elevator ooh I am not familiar with the
term space elevator cuz you're not as
geeky as row is aa row is on on the case
he's on the case huh on the case she
knows the deal she knows the deal what
is a space Elinor sure to name shows
name nerdy nummies nerdy nummies it's
like it should just be nerdy nerdy nerdy
ever nerdy ever everything everything so
space elevator here's how it works you
ready go ahead there's such cost
launching you into orbit right alright
you need the rocket you need the flaunt
pad you need all of this mm-hmm you got
to get up to 18th hour
miles and this is like we did a lot
going on they're not going on right okay
did you know that the farther away from
Earth you orbit this will make sense
when I say it the longer it takes to
complete in orbit that makes sense okay
it's like a record player like well no
the entire record it moves at the same
time at the same time right so it's not
like a record player no I'm saying it's
exactly not all parts of a record
complete one had the same right whereas
orbits the outer orbit travel slower and
takes longer to complete in one right so
just above Earth's surface takes about
90 minutes so low Earth orbit is close
enough
it takes about 90 minutes Space Shuttle
ninety minute orbit go higher can take
two hours little higher three hours four
hours five hours six hours 12 hours 15
hours 18 hours there is a distance that
you could put a satellite in orbit where
it takes 24 hours to orbit the Earth
okay so what does that mean it means if
you put a satellite up at that orbit it
stays with you yes all the way around it
is always hovering above your spot I
have the best cell phone this was the
idea put forth by arthur c clarke 1947
wasn't 46 just after the Second World
War he thought that if you put a
satellite at that distance which is
about 23,000 miles up you could Park one
over the Atlantic between Europe and the
United States and beam communication
signals right he came up with the idea
of the communication satellite nice so
that ring around the earth is filled
with communication satellites because we
know I'll know about this now wait a
minute if it hovers above a spot let's
put a platform there a space platform a
space station okay and dangled a rope
and just put an elevator there and just
take the elevator about to take the
elevator instead of it you don't have
the thousand pounds of fuel and weight
so we don't have to gain speed to have
bit too since stay in orbit and lower
this give a Yank no no you are yanking
leave that up there right but just you
have an elevator let them know to pull
you this is not a treehouse with a bell
the text no we got sophisticated way of
like okay let me up or some kind of room
we now take a long time to go twenty
twenty three thousand month that's a
long ways it's a long way you need I
there's a there's a friend of mine who
composed music hold space elevator music
that's pretty funny yes she composes
music under the name Zia and her name is
Elaine Walker she's got a whole album
called elevate him just just in time to
keep you busy for twenty twenty-five
thousand mile trip right actly yeah
exactly
so Oh so problem is we know of no
material that is strong enough to even
hold up its own weight in cable dangling
below such a space of a space station
Wow much less than attach an elevator to
it to ride up though there is a
substance that can do it what is it okay
do you remember buckyballs
this is carbon a new form of carbon
carbon sixty takes 60 carbon atoms and
they make a sphere that is are all the
nodes that are on the classical soccer
ball okay very cool right and it makes a
round thing right okay and it turns out
you can cut it in the middle and extend
it also with carbon atoms and make a a
Bucky tube alright it's hollow but it's
okay this is really really strong it is
strong enough to hold up its own weight
the problem is generating these things
and last I checked I don't have the
latest on this but last I checked the
longest we've made the longest tube
we've made because these are on a
molecular scale is about a centimeter
about a centimeter right so we got a
ways to go yes so only you know 20 2009
yeah miles to go solo we are far away
technologically from making a space
elevator
but the idea continues to tantalize
those who want easy access to space easy
and cheap and just to space going
forward so we're not there yet I don't
think it's gonna happen in our lifetime
by the way today we perfect carbon
they're called nanotubes right that
would transform construction everything
everything because it's really light and
really strong way stronger than steel
right you can make really tall guys
don't weigh anything and they wouldn't
even need the foundation structurally
you don't have to bit that's right
exactly that's pretty cool you gotta
watch out you don't want people just
push it up that's pretty cool I just
want to see the person who gets stuck in
the space elevator
[Laughter]
yeah so do you go Ralph why is Star Trek
the best show ever made and why is
Voyager the best season he disagrees I
think he likes a different season but
we're still friends because we both love
Star Trek yes you got that right okay
yeah well I'm with you too if you
disagree that Voyager is not the best
because it's not it is not it could be
when did you come of age right yeah
drives a Star Trek at every turning
point correct you know the 60s then I
think I think we have to wait to the 80s
oh I'm next generation there's neck that
next start Star Trek next gen but then
after that is Stuart that's right
number one engage I love it what one
yeah yes
how does he have he's he's got a French
name right with a British accent right
and he's 60 yeah I was wrong Luc Picard
captained up the USS Enterprise what's
up with that I'm actually 42 years old
okay so so so she got me right to where
I think deeply about this so I'm a fan
of the first season first I'm old enough
well everybody has to be a fan of the
first see you have no no yeah
oh you're not a true fan I mean you may
not like it best but it's where the
whole judgment are big people okay
the Borg was a great idea you know and
the visor and Jordi Jordi yeah there's
some good stuff happened later right we
finally got Janeway get a female captain
on there so so stuff had to happen later
on what I'm saying is in the original
season as was carried through that
spaceship a the USS Enterprise was the
first ship that I know of and I've
looked at that that was not designed
just to go to another place but was
simply conceived to explore that's right
every other space ship and every other
sci-fi thing right was okay we're using
this will go to market destination and
then it's in the shows about being on
Mars
this was just made to seek out and
discover new life new civilizations
right only go where no no has gone
before if you're gonna correct the
grammar be to go boldly right no split
infinitives and says your mama would say
if you were here absolutely so so I'd
like the fact that it pioneered a new
understanding of what it is to be in
space a be the captain actually fought
his own fights yes he did okay and he
beamed down on every away miss every he
beamed down and would fight and you
can't expect your crew to fight unless
you're gonna fight I just thought that
was not that fighting is a good thing
I'd rather no one fought but if you got
a fight you don't send someone else to
do your fighting that's right okay he
went down there to fight but he also
made sure that he was always gonna bring
a black crewman who he knew would die
no the crew just had to have a red shirt
that's true that's true that's a red
shirt that's okay you're right
see every show was a morality tale true
and I just thought who's doing this
maybe Twilight Zone at the time
otherwise those three things combined
made the
original Star Trek for me one of the
greatest mirrors to our own civilization
that has ever been put up under the
guise of oh this is just science fiction
you get to learn about yourself without
knowing that in fact the lesson is being
infused through your eyes and ears who
is that in the mirror who is that Neil
so that's my answer so I don't I'm not
gonna fight anybody who has a more
favorite season than the first one
uh-huh but I just want to say the first
one was groundbreaking in all those
fundamental ways so there you go okay I
listen I'll accept that so so there you
have it
Star Trek first generation Captain Kirk
oh plus plus Captain Kirk would use seat
of his pants reasoning I like that right
and Spock was always there to let him
know that everything he was doing was
allowed to be illogical right
it means Kirk would beat Spock at poker
every time that's basically they didn't
play the game but right this is like
you've got a bluff I know how to bluff
exactly I know how to read and you don't
all right one of my favorite episodes of
Star Trek from the original series okay
okay you ready go ahead okay
I don't remember the details and real
aficionados would like no chapter and
verse okay but here it is there's some
enemy vessel out the front window right
okay and Kirk's shields have a problem
coming back up and so they're kind of
susceptible okay mm-hmm and Kirk tells
Uhura open a channel open a chest open a
channel to Starfleet Command use the the
secure channel three one five six okay
tell them we are going to execute the
executive order whatever right right so
here's the thing that channel that
secure channel has been decoded right by
the enemy right and they know that okay
all right and but the enemy doesn't
think that Spock that Kirk knows this
and this executive order is
destructive the ship which would and
also destroy the ship that's ready to
attack them right okay so Spock
here's this and knows that that channels
already been compromised and said
captain you realize that's no longer a
secure channel this is no time for a
game of chess and he says to Spock Spock
I am NOT playing chess it's rock this is
not chess this is poker this and I said
that is so good yeah you're staring
somebody down and you Bluff right and
they don't know you're bluffing right
and you got a really badass Bluff that's
there's a secret message over a decoded
channel right that they don't know that
you know is they coded he know did you
know that's right
Lawton I know that you know that I know
Norton I've seen that episode but no one
under 50 has seen that episode of The
Honeymooners so I'd like the fact that
Kirk could use his intuition that would
not be anchored in logic to make a
decision that was in the interest of the
safety of the crew it sounds to me like
Captain Kirk is just very reckless you
know just lose a pack as buddy now I
don't mean to brag I don't mean to brag
I was quoted on the latest iteration of
Star Trek's discovery Star Trek
discovery on CBS that's right quoted by
Spock get out yes yes I was just saying
I don't mean to brag okay so here it was
it's like
Spock is having this moment of
existential angst and you hearing his
thoughts right and he says do I exist
and how do I exist in a quantum
multiverse and could I this he's having
this moment okay and in there he says as
a paraphrasing as an ancient earth
scientist once said the universe is
under no obligation to
sense to me oh my god I saw that who did
see that yes he did use my name I'm just
some ancient earth scientist right
that's mark and that's my quote yeah
that's very cool brag but that's what so
Chuck yeah I was on nerdy nummies oh yes
what'd you do when I baked a cake oh
that's very nice it was very very fun it
was inspired by a single episode of Star
Trek Voyager cool yeah now you got to go
click on if you want to see yeah I want
to eat it how do I click on that right
there anywhere oh thanks for those
questions